I'm James Maynard and I'm a math
addition at the University of Oxford
he works on prime numbers all whole
numbers are built up of prime numbers
multiplied together so for
mathematicians like me prime numbers
take this fundamental role of like atoms
that make up all whole numbers but the
really interesting thing is despite them
being these fundamental building blocks
of numbers they're still really poorly
understood and there's lots of basic
questions about them that we haven't
been able to answer even though they've
been studied for thousands of years
I'm always drawn to simple to state
mathematical problems that have
exceptionally difficult and interesting
answers for example one of my favorite
problems in mathematics it's the twin
prime conjecture that asks if there's
infinitely many pairs of primes that
differ by just two this is a really
famous problem that mathematicians have
considered for well over a hundred years
but we still don't know the answer to it
so one problem I worked on was showing
that there's infinitely many prime
numbers that have none of their decimal
digits equal to the number 7 it's a very
rare property for very large numbers to
have no sevens in their decimal
expansion and there's lots of really
important problems about prime numbers
that ask whether there's infinitely many
Prime's that have some rare property so
this is a proof of concept in that
direction
it's an interesting problem because you
can consider a weak variance of the
problem and I'd proved a weaker version
and I've been working really hard to try
and get to the full version of the
answer that I wanted when I finally
solved there I was really happy that I
was able to finally get over this
obstacle was I've been stuck for several
months but at the same time I was
actually a bit concerned because I was
worried that I was going to embarrass
myself in front of everyone if there's a
mistake in my work